Hallo Stefan.
Wie ist das Wetter?
Das Wetter ist sehr trüb, also es ist doch ein ganz eigenartiger Sommer. Es war ja auch schon ein komischer Frühling und eigentlich hätten wir ja Wärme gut brauchen können. Und dieser Effekt ist aber dann nicht eingetreten und jetzt ist es auch wieder ein sehr trüber Tag. Umso besser, dass wir viel anbieten zum Lesen. Und ich möchte dabei erst noch mal drei Hinweise aufgreifen, die ich bekommen habe. Resonanz auf unseren Podcasts, auf die vergangene Folge. Und zwar, ich nenne jetzt einfach mal die Vornamen, weil ich ja nicht weiß, ob alle Leute mal so ganz genannt werden wollen. Rainer hat mir geschrieben, er hat das mit Interesse gehört, was wir da zu Google gesagt haben, dass Google jetzt die Erinnerungen für uns löscht oder bearbeitet oder Dinge einfügt, die gar nicht stattgefunden haben. Und dann meinte er, ich sollte mich doch mal mit dem Film Eternal Sunshine of a Spotless Mind auseinandersetzen. Und dann schrieb er aber, dann sei ihm aufgefallen, das habe ich ja schon mal gemacht für so ein Bonusmaterial bei der DVD. Und tatsächlich ist dieser Film von Michel Gontry ganz, ganz großartig. Ich kann den sehr empfehlen, denn dort wird versucht, tatsächlich von einem Unternehmen, das Gedächtnis von Menschen zu löschen bzw. irgendwelche Erlebnisse, die sie hatten, rauszulöschen. Oder auch z.B. Partner, die man hatte, dass man sagte, ich möchte mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern an diese Ehe. Also löscht mir den doch raus. Es ist ein ganz großartiger Film mit Jim Carrey. Und das ist vielleicht ein sehr, sehr guter Beitrag zu dem Google-Kram, den wir da besprochen haben.
Da will ich mal den Hinweis machen. Wir haben tatsächlich eine sehr gute Diskussion diesmal auf der Webseite. Heute ist ja wieder Steady sozusagen erster Anlaufpunkt. Aber kommentiert doch bitte auf der Webseite, weil dann kann Wolfgang auch alle Kommentare sehen. Das ist nämlich bei Steady, da gibt es aber nur einen Admin-Account und so. Irgendwie ist es ein bisschen schwierig, das dann darzustellen. Und die Webseite hat ja Kommentare da. Und zu Google und Lambda und so finden sich da auch noch andere Kommentare. Die kann man nochmal nachlesen. Sehr gut.
Wunderbar. Dann hat mir Mona geschrieben über Instagram, dass sie auch schon auf diese Schäden gestoßen sei, die bei Rezo auftaucht und die ja in der Phono-Branche unterwegs ist. Und zwar würde die auch in einigen Funk-Formaten stattfinden. Das habe ich dann auch gesehen, dass sie also auch dort drin ist. Sie scheint wohl über eine sehr gute Agentur zu verfügen oder über die richtigen Kontakte. Das noch dazu.
Also, Phono-Darsteller im normalen Medienbetrieb zu installieren ist nicht leicht. Da haben schon einige versucht diesen, wie heißt die eine, Gina Wild oder so?
Genau, aber die sind ja dann alle immer so Aussteigerinnen gewesen. Bei Dolly Buster war das ein bisschen anders, aber das war, glaube ich, dann generell so als glamouröser Star ist die dann so ein bisschen und ein bisschen Trash-TV etabliert worden. Oder auch noch Theresa Olowsky, die saßen dann damals so in Gottschalks Sendungen und mal bei Harald Schmidt und Feuerstein. Aber das ist dann bei Michaela Schafrath dann so gewesen, dass sie, glaube ich, ausgestiegen war. Und dann kann man darüber erzählen, dass es dann immer so eine andere Sache, die ja dann auch als Boulevard-Schauspielerin ein bisschen erfolgreich dann auch war. Und jetzt gibt es noch einen dritten Punkt. Und zwar hat mir Adrian das auch über Instagram geschrieben. Ich hatte doch angemerkt, dass in diesen Videos No Friends, aber auch in den Videos von MyTea immer wieder zu sehen ist, dass man dort vor der Kamera sitzt und eine Kaffee oder Teetasse in der Hand hat. Und Adrian hat mir da einen Artikel geschickt, der heißt Wärme macht warmherzig aus der Süddeutschen Zeitung von 2010. Und da haben Wissenschaftler der Universität in Colorado und der Yale University ein Experiment durchgeführt. Und zwar ist erstmal diese Prämisse, wer beim Flirten einen guten Eindruck machen will, sollte das bei einem warmen Kaffee tun. Eis essen ist dagegen weniger zu empfehlen. Und das haben jetzt diese zwei amerikanischen Psychologen herausgefunden. Und zwar haben sie ein Experiment gemacht. Eine Frau ist im Aufzug. Sie haben das dann mit vielen Probern durchgespielt. Eine Frau ist im Aufzug, hat ganz viele Dinge in der Hand und muss, hat aber auch noch einen Kaffee oder einen Eiskaffee. Also entweder warm oder kalt. Und das hat sie. Und dann gibt sie das denen, die dort mit dem Aufzug stehen, mit der Bitte, können sie es mal kurz halten. Und danach sollen diese Testpersonen dann beschreiben, wie diese Person ist, die Charaktereigenschaften. Obwohl sie die nur ganz kurz gesehen haben. Und natürlich passiert das, was man sich dann vielleicht doch intuitiv denken kann. Die, die die warme Tasse bekommen haben, haben dann diese Person auch als warmherzig beschrieben und die anderen eher als kalt. Wenn wir einen anderen Menschen als warm beschreiben, denken wir dabei eigentlich nicht an physikalische Wärme, sagt Lawrence Williams. Doch unsere Ergebnisse zeigen, dass die doppelte Bedeutung des Wortes warm nicht zufällig ist. Sie haben also auf diesen Zusammenhang hingewiesen. Und das sei auch gar nicht so außergewöhnlich, wenn man das sich unter neurobiologischen Prämissen ansieht. Nämlich, dass diese Empfindungen von physischer und psychischer Wärme in derselben Hirnregion lokalisiert sind. Sorgt dafür, dass das sehr eng miteinander gekoppelt ist. Und möglicherweise also gibt es diesen Effekt dann auch bei uns Zuschauern, dass wir da eine Protagonistin in einem Video sehen mit einer Tasse in der Hand. Da ist was Warmes drin und dann sagt man herrlich. Das ist aber doch was, was es sehr menschlich macht. Und was sehe ich dann, als ich diesen Artikel gelesen habe? Ich klicke YouTube an und da ist der Algorithmus ja auf mich trainiert. Was zeigt er mir also an? Ein Interview mit Sofia Loren oder wie wir in Deutschland ja gerne sagen, Sofia Loren, der großen italienischen Schauspielerin, die ja weit über 80 inzwischen ist, jetzt in einem Film mitspielt und die unterhält sich dort in einem Zoom-Call zu ihrem Film mit einer Moderatorin und beide, die Moderatorin wie auch Sofia Loren, haben eine Tee-Tasse dort und sie trinken dann auch und thematisieren das sogar. Und Sofia Loren sagt, ist dann bei ihnen auch wirklich was drin oder ist das nur eine Tasse? Also sehr schön. Es scheint wohl sehr wichtig zu sein, wenn man auf YouTube erfolgreich sein will, dann mit einem Heißgetränk.
Ja, sehr gut. Weil dann nutzt man ja die eigentlich nicht gefühlte Wärme, sondern nur die imaginierte Wärme. Ja, und macht sozusagen überwannene diese Transferleistungen bei seinem Publikum. Da haben wir ja was gelernt. Kann man das nutzen im Alltag? Wir wissen es nicht genau. Junge Menschen, die ihre Schwärme treffen, können ja mal die Warme, aus welchen Vorwänden auch immer, die warme Tasse mal kurz rüberreichen.
So, ja.
Zu sagen, hältst du mal, ich muss vor dir auf die Knie gehen, mein Schuh ist offen. Sehr gut. Dann noch ein Wort zu Sachsen-Anhalt. Denn wir wollen nicht warten bis Monatsende. Aber es ist schon beeindruckend, dass in den Medien so ein bisschen, oh, die AfD könnte ja und so weiter da richtig reinknallen. Und dann ist so ein Wahlamt durch. Und plötzlich ist die CDU fast doppelt so weit vor der AfD, wie vorher prognostiziert wurde.
Man fragt sich dann immer, was soll eigentlich dann noch die Meinungsumfrage? Was sollen diese ganzen tollen Institute? Wir haben das ja in den USA schon gesehen. Und nun ist das alles ein bisschen komplexer als in einem Bundesland. Aber hier kann man ja deutlich wieder sehen, was für ein Alarmismus da dann tagelang gespielt wird. Und dann fragt man sich schon, welchen Effekt hat das eigentlich? Und ist das dann nicht vielleicht sogar ein negativer Effekt für die anderen Parteien? Also für Grüne, Linke, für SPD? Also die haben ja zum Teil winzig zugenommen oder abgenommen. Dann die Grünen sind ein bisschen stärker. Aber da kann man nun wirklich jetzt nicht von einem Schub reden. Die SPD hat nochmal verloren. Und das hat mich dann auch immens geärgert, dass Karl Lauterbach dann Haselhoff nicht nur gratulierte, sondern sagte, das sei ein Sieg für uns alle, auch wenn die eigenen Parteien nicht gut abgeschrieben haben. Das halte ich für sehr, sehr schwierig, wenn man das jetzt so macht. Denn dann kann man auch einfach sagen, dann tun wir uns doch alle jetzt zusammen, von FDP bis Linke. Und die nennen sich dann einfach die Superdemokraten. Da brauchen wir diese anderen Parteien nicht mehr. Wir sind dann nur noch da, um die AfD zu verhindern. Und ich hatte heute auf Twitter dahingewiesen, würde das hier auch nochmal tun. Und wir verlinken den auch. Es gibt einen sehr, sehr guten Text von Slavoj Zizek, der ist aus dem Jahr 2000. Und dieser Text hat einen schönen Titel, warum wir es lieben, Haider zu hassen. Und damals gab es ja in Österreich den Rechtspopulisten Haider. Und alle waren so im liberalen Establishment sich natürlich darüber einig, dass Haider ganz schlimm ist. Und dann sagt Zizek, naja, das stimmt auch alles. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man jetzt so eine gemeinsame Querfront bildet gegen die Haider-Partei und dann sagt, wir sind aber die guten Demokraten und das reicht dann. Nämlich schreibt dann folgendes, hier spielt die liberaldemokratische neue Mitte, wie sie in Deutschland genannt wird, ein doppeltes Spiel. Sie setzt uns Rechtspopulisten als gemeinsamen wahren Feind vor, während sie in Wirklichkeit diese Panik gegenüber der Rechten manipuliert, um im demokratischen Feld eine Hegemonie zu errichten, das heißt das Terrain abzustecken und ihren wahren Feind, die radikale Linke, für sich zu gewinnen und zu disziplinieren. Aber durch die Ereignisse wie die Regierungsbeteiligung von Heidas Partei, die, das sollten wir nicht vergessen, vor ein paar Jahren ein Vorläufer in Italien hatte, die Beteiligung von Finesse neofaschistischer Allianznazionale an der Regierung Berlusconis, bekommt die postpolitische und postideologisch neue Mitte ihre eigenen Nachrichten umgekehrter wahrer Form zurück. Die Regierungsbeteiligung der extremen Rechten ist der Preis, den die Linke bezahlt, weil sie jedem radikalen politischen Projekt abgeschworen und den Marktkapitalismus als the only game in town akzeptiert hat. Und da sehe ich auch nach wie vor dieses große Problem, wann könnte es dann doch mal dazu kommen, dass das nicht so eindeutig ist, wie Lauterbach das in seinem Tweet beschreibt, sondern dass es ja durchaus sehr viele Kräfte in der CDU schon gibt, die sagen auch, wir könnten da aber auch mal koalieren oder uns zumindest dulden lassen und so weiter. Und wie steht man dann am Ende da? Insofern muss man aufpassen, dass dieser Linksliberalismus dann nicht zum Wegbereiter wird für eine solche unheilige Allianz. Insofern, glaube ich, geht es vielmehr darum, sich genau zu positionieren, abzugrenzen von rechts sowieso, aber auch dann von der CDU mit ganz eigenen Projekten. Und wenn da jetzt SPD, Grüne und Linke wirklich nur so eine Schadensbegrenzung machen wollen, das ist auch zu wenig. Das ist auch als Anreiz zu wenig für Wähler, für Wechselwähler oder für Nichtwähler.
Genau, es gibt diese inhaltliche Tiefe. Also in der Ansicht wird es nochmal sehr interessant, sich das Sachsen-Anhaltinische Ergebnis anzuschauen. Und ich sehe auch in der Performance so eine Gefahr, dass man die AfD zu so einer Deko verklärt, an der man sich abarbeitet. So eine Kulisse, vor der man schnell wegrennen kann, damit man noch Bewegungen simulieren kann irgendwie. Denn es macht glaube ich wenig Sinn, vor jeder Wahl die AfD als so eine riesige Gefahr darzustellen, wenn sie dann doch unter ihren eigenen Erwartungen und unseren Befürchtungen bleibt. Also solche Erweckungsmomente wie, ah, puh, nochmal gut gegangen, 13% Vorsprung für die CDU. Also das ist dann auch albern. Entweder es ist eng oder es ist nicht eng. Und das was Lauterbach da formuliert oder postuliert, dass es die Demokraten gibt, während gleichzeitig die Demokraten eigentlich bei Anne Wildern sitzen am Abend und sagen, ne, wir müssen eigentlich alles dafür tun, damit wir nicht als dieser Einheitsbrei gelten, als den uns jetzt Lauterbach wieder hinstellt. Da würde ich sagen, es gibt Formen Lauterbachs Denken da zu legitimieren, aber da braucht man schon so ein Bild wie Russland. Und dann ist es auch nicht ein Kampf gegen eine ganz rechtsaußen Opposition, sondern dann ist es die fiese, diktatorische Regierungspartei, gegen die man dann im nawalnischen Sinne einfach alle Alternativen bündelt. Aber mit dem echten Ziel, halt wirklich eine Regierung demokratisch zu beseitigen oder zu stürzen oder wie auch immer. Aber halt auf demokratische, also die demokratischen Möglichkeiten nutzen, das zu machen und nicht das Gegenteil, sich nochmal zu schmücken in einer eigentlich gut funktionierenden Demokratie, in der man dann rechtsaußen immer zu hoch hängt.
Ja, und man bestätigt doch auch die Leute damit, die sagen, naja, die sind ja eh alle eins.
Genau.
Genau, das tut man ja nochmal damit bekräftigen, indem man einen solchen Tweet loslässt oder dann auch diesen Pappkamerad die ganze Zeit aufstellt, da selbst, wo er eigentlich gar nicht da ist. Und das konnten wir doch jetzt auch erleben, dass die AfD keinen großen Zugewinn mehr schaffen konnte, dass sie auch jetzt wieder ein bisschen sogar verloren hat. Und das ist ja genug Anlass aus irgendwelchen Sachen wie Corona und so gegeben hätte, dass die AfD jetzt nochmal als die große Alternative ganz, ganz vielen Leuten erscheint, was aber nicht der Fall ist. Und dann kann man das ja auch einfach mal akzeptieren, darüber froh sein und sich dann mit den eigenen Dingen befassen, weil das passiert ja kaum. Also das ist ja ganz, ganz entsetzlich. Und wenn jetzt, wo die CDU so sehr in der Kritik ist und auch diese Spitzenminister in der Kritik sind, allen voran sparen, dass die jetzt nochmal ihr Ergebnis wesentlich verbessern konnte, das ist doch auch ein ganz, ganz trauriges Zeichen.
Also das ist mal zu hinterfragen. Gut, da gibt es in Ostdeutschland, insbesondere, aber wir haben es auch in Baden-Württemberg gesehen, immer diesen wirklichen Amtsbonus, der jetzt eine echte Rolle zu spielen scheint, egal aus welcher Partei. Hat auch viel mit Bekanntheit und Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu tun. Ein Wort noch mal zur AfD. Die AfD wichtiger zu nehmen als sie ist. Es gibt ja von Schling-Sief, es gibt ja jetzt diese Doku, die Schling-Sief nochmal selber spricht die ganze Zeit, wo er nochmal ganz hervorragend dargestellt wird. Und wo er auch diese Idee drin hat, man muss sich an den Nazis jetzt abarbeiten. Also man muss sie jetzt, man darf sie nicht immer so, oder hat jemand, was weiß ich, irgendeinen Konzentrationslager beim Namen genannt, also da stahlen wir jetzt mal alle vor Erfurcht und verwandeln jetzt das Gespräch, welches auch immer gestaltet war, in ein Seminar, wo sich alle ganz kurz benehmen, weil jetzt geht es um die deutsche Staatsrisse. Nee, man muss sich auch mal über Nazis lustig machen können. Und es ist ein Bild aufgetaucht die Woche von Björn Höcke mit einer Krawatte, die nicht schwarz-rot-gold war, sondern wo die Flagge falsch rum drauf war. Schwarz oben, Gold unten. Und das ist irgendwie symbolisch aufgeladen in diesen Kreisen, um so ein Statement zu machen. Man nimmt zwar die eigentliche echte Farbe, also man nimmt nicht schwarz-rot-weiß, aber man verkehrt es halt doch so, dass es so eine kleine Devianz erkennbar ist. Und das hat auf Twitter jemand kommentiert mit, ah, die Nazis kennen nicht mal die deutsche Flagge, auf die sie ja so stolz sind. Und ich habe da drüber getwittert einfach so drei lachende Smilies, woraufhin auf Twitter ein RepliStorm losging mit Hinweisen. Und zwar immer so ernsthaft grauend, dass das ja eine ganz kluge, ganz raffinierte Kommunikation von Björn Höcke ist, die ich nicht durchschaut habe. Und jetzt bin ich sozusagen auf ihn reingefallen. Dann will ich doch hier noch mal sagen, ne, Björn Höcke hat die deutschen Farmen einfach falsch rumgetragen. Und es ist absolut lächerlich, egal unter welchen Bewandnissen das zu machen. Und nur weil man vor 30 Jahren mal auf eine Idee kam, da so ein Zeichen rein zu interpretieren, heißt das noch nicht, dass ich dieses Zeichen akzeptiere in dieser gemeinten Ernsthaftigkeit, dass man damit jetzt das Signal gibt, der Tag X rückt nah und jetzt muss die Verteidigungs- und Wehrfähigkeit hier mal hochgejesst werden oder wie auch immer. Sondern ich sehe da einfach nur einen Geschichtslehrer, der nicht in der Lage ist, die deutschen Farben ordentlich zu verwenden und mache mich dann entsprechend darüber lustig. Und das möchte ich doch empfehlen, dass man jetzt mal so eine etwas lockere Handhabe der AfD gegenüber nimmt, weil wir kennen diese Partei jetzt. Es gibt jetzt nichts mehr zu entzaubern, auch nicht für die Wähler, wer die wählt. Es ist jetzt alles geklärt, wir wissen jetzt, um was es da geht. Und deswegen jetzt mal ein bisschen Abklärung. Man muss nicht immer die ganze Aufklärung hier und da nochmal und hier nochmal der Hinweis, sondern jetzt einfach mal abgeklärt ein bisschen drüber stehen und sagen, das ist wirklich auch eine Quatschpartei.
Ganz genau. Und eigentlich ist das ein literaturwissenschaftlicher Ansatz, der schon in den 70er Jahren etabliert wurde. Das ist der rezeptionsästhetische Ansatz, der sagt, wir gucken mal, wie die Leser das rezipieren. Uns interessieren überhaupt jetzt nicht die Autoren, sondern was machen die Leser mit dem Text. Und der Leser, Stefan Schulz, sieht die Krawatte und sagt, was soll dieser Programm? Das ist doch ein Geschichtslachslehrer. Das ist ja lachhaft und deswegen mache ich mich darüber lustig. Und ich frage jetzt nicht, was will der Autor mir damit sagen. Das ist nur noch die Hermeneutik. Das ist noch die alte Betrachtungsweise von Literatur. Was will der Autor uns damit sagen? War Kafka wirklich krank? Hat er ein Problem mit seinem Vater? Interessiert gar nicht, sondern wir wollen wissen, was sagt der Text uns über das digitale Zeitalter oder so.
So ist es. Und wir gehen jetzt in den Salon, lesen dort ein Buch, das du nicht so gut fandest, ich aber supergut finde. Antitrust von Amy Klobuchar. Ich bin allerdings auch überrascht, wie sich es entfaltet hat. Ich habe ein anderes Buch erwartet.
Ja, und ich werde jetzt was entgegenhalten. Das will ich schon sagen. Ich werde dir Lenin entgegenhalten. Jetzt wird es wirklich schlimm, ne?
Gehen wir nochmal die Jahrhunderte durch. Sehr gut. Wagenknecht werden wir lesen. Ich werde es verreißen. Aber ich muss auch sagen, gestern bei Anne Willer hat sie wieder Glänzen abgeliefert. Also ich bin ein bisschen hin und hergerissen, werde das entsprechend gleich einordnen. Wir lesen bestürzende Sachen über Beatmungs-WGs. In Deutschland gibt es medizinische Zustände. Es ist atemberaubend. Frauen haben ein Buch darüber geschrieben, was sie für Nachrichten von Männern auf ihren Handy kriegen. Das ist nun Kommunikation. Man könnte nun denken, was macht der Urstein-Verlag? Da kommen zwei Frauen und sagen, wir möchten ein Buch darüber schreiben, was wir für ein SMS bekommen. Also SMS im Sinne von Messenger, egal welche Plattform. Und beim Lesen habe ich festgestellt, das ist nun mal der absolut privateste und nicht öffentlich einsehbare Bereich. Nicht mal Ehe-Männer wissen, was ihre Ehefrauen für Nachrichten und so weiter bekommen. Da mal reinzuschauen, ist dann doch ganz interessant, wenn Frauen, und zwar mal nicht so aus dieser Opferrolle, ich habe schon wieder einen Dickpick bekommen, wo kann ich mich hier beschweren, wer macht denn die Gesetze, sondern wo einfach mal ein bisschen alltäglich referiert wird, was geht da vor sich. Ja und das letzte Ding, 25 Edits der modernen Videogeschichte, da bin ich gespannt, was du davon hältst. Das geht so in die nicht Filmrichtung, aber es hat mit Bewegung zu tun.
Was muss ein Sound unterlegt werden, eine lustige Musik und ein Jump-Cut und alles Mögliche. Wir werden uns dann auch mit Literatur auseinandersetzen. Ich hatte es schon angekündigt. Einmal, wir gehen ins 19. Jahrhundert mit Tugenev, wir gehen ins 20. Jahrhundert mit Mishima und ins 21. Jahrhundert, aber wirklich ins 21. Jahrhundert mit Jonas Eicher. Das wird sehr, sehr grandios, was der Eicher da macht. Und wir sprechen über Porn ab. Wer steckt eigentlich dahinter? Welches Unternehmen? Es gibt da ein Unternehmen, das wurde auch jetzt schon ein paar Mal genannt, MindGeek, aber wem gehört das eigentlich? Das weiß man nämlich gar nicht so genau. Es ist eine absolut verrückte Geschichte. Und dann blicken wir noch auf Staatsbürgerschaft heute. Da gibt es einen sehr guten Text zu.
Na dann folgt uns alle in den Salon. Wir haben gesehen, die 2-2-2 haben wir jetzt übersprungen. Also bis gleich im Salon.